SCP-682 was once at the mercy of the liminal
abyss known as the backrooms, but now the
hard to destroy reptile has become a master
of the backrooms.
After absorbing the essence of the Skeleton
Queen, along with several other powerful Backrooms
entities, SCP-682 had become powerful enough
to create its own level of the Backrooms - Level
682.
If you can’t beat the backrooms, become
the backrooms.
In its latest adapted form, 682 was able to
command the lesser entities of the backrooms,
such as clumps, death moths, and hounds.
These entities were now at the beck and call
of 682, and could be deployed at a moment’s
notice to savage trespassers on 682’s level.
While it was nearly unfathomable to believe
that any human explorer could survive the
long journey from Level 0 to Level 682, challengers
would soon arrive to attempt to snatch the
proverbial crown from 682’s reptilian head.
The death of the Skeleton Queen had upset
the balance of the backrooms, and now there
were countless other supernatural beings that
wanted a taste of the scrappy newcomer.
The first two warriors to arrive were the
infamous spear-using humanoids - Entity 74
“Argos” and Entity 720 “Tiny”.
Other than a shared weapon of choice and a
mutual hatred for SCP-682, these two entities
had little in common.
But the sting of their previous defeats at
the claws of their hated rival had compelled
the two to make their way to Level 682 and
face the lizard once more.
Argos bellowed as he entered into the devastated
wasteland of Level 682.
He had appeared first, accompanied by his
specially-trained retinue of human soldiers
in tactical gear - The Eyes of Argos.
Each one wielded a lesser replica of their
immortal leader’s signature spear, and all
were ready for battle.
Faced with these intruders, all SCP-682 could
do was laugh wickedly.
Its own army of hostile entities stood at
attention, leering at the humans.
“Entity 74 - Argos.”
SCP-682 greeted its visitor.
“Even without eyes in that swollen head
of yours, you must see that you cannot win
this.”
Argos roared that 682 was a sinner, and his
judgment was here.
Argos pointed his spear, and the Eyes of Argos
charged towards 682, who - in-turn - raised
a claw and signaled its own forces to meet
the Eyes on the field of combat.
Level 682 of the Backrooms was now a battlefield!
Human soldiers and entities were clashing
in pitched warfare.
Argos broke through the front lines and turned
his spear on 682.
The reptile merely grinned through all of
its teeth as Argos’ spear was deflected
effortlessly off its hide.
Argos struck again and again, but it seemed
that the eyeless giant had totally underestimated
682’s new form.
This was not going to be the same fight as
the previous time the two had met, with the
level of strength that the reptile had amassed,
it might not even be anything that could be
considered a fight.
At least, not if it remained a one-on-one
battle.
Fortunately for Argos, the other of the Backrooms
spear duo was about to make a splash.
Literally.
A gateway to Level 7 - the endless ocean - opened
above the battlefield, causing an untold quantity
of water to flow into the war zone of Level
682.
The gargantuan and grossly misnamed Tiny descended
through the portal, swimming through the stream
towards SCP-682.
It was chaos as both Argos and 682’s minions
were swept up in the current and drowned out.
Argos was frustrated at the sudden loss of
his army, but 682 couldn’t care less about
what happened to the Backrooms entities that
had temporarily bought themselves a bit more
time in existence by pledging loyalty to their
reptile master.
It was, after all, only a matter of time before
682 had gotten sick of them and destroyed
the miserable entities on a whim.
Serious contenders only.
“Your entrance was sinful.”
Argos spat towards Tiny, as the rushing water
submerged him.
“My entrance, like everything I do, was
perfect.”
Tiny scoffed.
“Now are you going to aid in my revenge
against this loathsome beast or are you going
to be sanctimonious as usual?”
The spear duo acknowledged each other, and,
putting aside their differences in a temporary
alliance, dove for 682 in an attempt to overwhelm
the hard-to-destroy reptile.
The tips of both spears collided with 682
and managed to push the creature a short distance
across the now-submerged landscape of its
level.
In retaliation, 682 trades its claws for a
number of flexible tentacles that were able
to push off the ground and propel the Level
master towards its two adversaries.
It grappled Argos with its long, flexible
arms and swung him against the solid surface
of the ground.
The eyeless warrior countered by stabbing
one of 682’s tentacles, but the clever reptile
shed the tentacle immediately and jettisoned
toward Tiny.
The massive humanoid attempted to stab 682,
but was unable to hit his target as his opponent
used its tentacles to grab Tiny’s body and
maneuver around him effortlessly.
In a case of further irony, 682 was using
its smaller size to its advantage against
Tiny.
Meanwhile, Argos was just now coming to grips
with a disadvantage of its own.
While on land, the sin-hunter was quite capable
of sustaining countless injuries and regenerating
from the damage, its respiratory system had
no way to evacuate the water that had not
begun to fill the humanoid’s lungs.
Though he was immortal: Argos was drowning.
Even his unlimited stamina couldn’t prevent
his body from slowing down.
At this moment, both entities were unable
to gain a significant advantage over 682.
Moreover, the lack of cohesion between their
tactics was leaving both open to a counterattack.
This was precisely the kind of opportunity
that 682 had been waiting for.
While in its prior state, the hard-to-destroy
reptile was only able to adapt its own physique,
but now that it had become one with a portion
of the backrooms, it had gained the ability
to adapt its level as well.
In an instant, 682 asserted its control over
its domain and expunged the water from Level
7 back into the liminal nothingness between
levels.
While Argos could now stand back on solid
ground, it was sluggish and immobilized by
the water in its body.
He attempted to gag and force the water out,
but leaving that kind of opening was a time
that Entity 74 didn’t have.
Entity 720 came crashing down upon Argos,
smothering the entity beneath its thalassic
bulk.
While underwater, Tiny was a force to reckoned
with, the entity was incapable of walking
on land.
It was now little more than a beached whale
in the shape of a humanoid giant.
Having now immobilized both of its adversaries,
682 was quite proud of itself.
It whipped at Tiny with its fearsome tentacles,
adding insult to injury with deep wounds across
the giant’s entire form.
Spear-carriers don’t belong on the main
stage.
Drawing from the same wellspring of power
that allowed it to absorb the Skeleton Queen,
SCP-682 devoured the essence of both Entity
74 and Entity 720.
Just like the time before, the hard-to-destroy
reptile went one step further than mere consumption.
The reptilian master of dimensions assimilated
and incorporated elements of Level 7 and Level
10 into the exponentially growing borders
of Level 682.
Now that it was victorious against the two
spear-wielding humanoids, 682 let out a mighty
roar that echoed throughout all the remaining
levels of the backrooms.
The message to all dimensional rulers on every
level was crystal clear - if they didn’t
come to level 682 to challenge its master,
the reptile would bring the challenge to each
and every one of them.
I am the Backrooms, and when my kingdom comes,
I will be all there is.
While most of the entities and humans on the
other levels cowered in fear, there were several
who still wished to stand and fight.
The next opponent that would confront SCP-682
in an attempt to slay the creature was none
other than the blue knight of level 28.
The brightly-shining suit of armor strode
into Level 682, carrying a raging storm behind
it.
Hurricane-force winds beat down on 682, followed
by an unforgiving rain of lightning bolts.
The reptile weathered the storm and struck
back with a vicious bite that crushed the
armor of the Blue Knight’s arm and part
of his chestplate.
Then, 682 turned like a crocodile in a death
roll, inflicting even more damage to the sentient
armor.
With his free gauntlet, the blue knight pounded
on 682’s head, bringing down even more lightning
and wind on the reptile.
Your storm is weak.
I feel disgusting having to use my immense
power to dispel it.
Yet again, 682 manipulated its level of the
Backrooms, causing the storm that the blue
knight had called to be banished into the
void between levels.
The blue knight was aghast.
The reason he had always stayed on Level 28
was to spare the humans of more settled levels
from the wrathful storm clouds that he was
known to create in his moments of emotional
outbursts.
It was his most shameful curse, and yet 682
had made it disappear as simply as morning
mist.
The now powerless blue knight could do nothing
as he, too, was devoured by 682.
His next words were a plea for a wish that
could never come true.
“I wish I could have seen you one more time,
Sara.”
Like Argos and Tiny before him, The Blue Knight
and his corresponding Level 28 had become
part of 682 now.
682 was starting to get accustomed to the
feeling of devouring levels of the Backrooms.
The taste was invigorating, and out of a sense
of malicious initiative, the reptilian entity
went on an unplanned rampage through the surrounding
levels.
While it was nothing more than a trivial test
of the incredible power at its disposal, 682
was able to drink in more of the Backrooms
essence, and soon it was beginning to reshape
the liminal abyss itself.
Countless entities were nothing more than
cannon fodder to the unstoppable machine of
destruction that 682 had become.
As foe after foe fell prey to Entity 682 - master
of the backrooms - more of the other levels
began to disappear as they were absorbed into
Level 682.
The reptile was on a violent spree at this
point, and could almost imagine itself back
at the foundation, painting the walls with
mobile task force agents and researchers alike.
In its frenzy, SCP-682 found itself once again
face-to-face with the Plush Dino of Level
18.
The despised Entity 198 who served as a guide
for lost and distressed souls, and had once
regarded SCP-682 as the most tormented being
in existence.
Even now, the Plush Dino’s instinct to reach
out to those suffering from terrible anguish
had guided it to the new and improved 682.
682 had always disliked 198, and was especially
resentful that it had chosen to appear now.
Did its presence mean that deep inside, 682
was still suffering from the scars of its
past?
No.
I have overcome that.
Adapted.
I always do.
682 stepped forward as if to consume its next
victim, but a nagging feeling stopped it from
committing to the attack.
If it were to devour the plush dino there
was a possibility that it would also consume
Level 18, a subjective realm that would always
transform to recreate the childhood traumas
of the explorer inside of it.
682 had not been afraid to face its traumatic
past during its journey through the earlier
layers of the backroom, but to make the echo
of those painful memories a permanent part
of its form seemed to be a bridge too far.
Besides…
What would Jerry think of me?
SCP-682 caught itself thinking of Entity 7
again.
It was frozen with indecision, unsure whether
or not to devour Entity 198 on the spot.
Then, a sudden blaze of scorching flames snapped
682 back to the present moment.
This gasp of the inferno caused the plush
dino to turn tail and move to a different
level of the backrooms. 682 was now surrounded
by fire at some distant level that it had
never seen before.
On the horizon stood a vast army of flaming
beings, glowing with a solar light that gave
off an unbelievable amount of heat.
Presiding above all others in this militant
fire army was the apparent leader, a six-armed
bright red humanoid whose regal features were
as imposing as the halos of sunflare that
adorned his fingertips.
This unfathomable being would soon be 682’s
latest and, thus far, greatest challenger.
He was a legend of the backrooms and the true
ruler of the warlike dimension of Level 966
- the inferno.
An ancient god whose relentless forest-fires
had chased Lord Wormwood and his tree people
to the brink of extinction.
The forgemaster who pulled the flame-o’-the-golden
from the all-brilliance and made it his source
of power.
This was Rajarahan the Golden Kindle, Prince
of Fires of Light.
“Oh, Great Beast of Level 682.
I, Rajarahan, have heard the tales of your
glorious conquest throughout the liminal spaces
of these Backrooms.
I have heard that you hail from the Front
Rooms and are the uncontested strongest being
from that reality.
I am here to answer your summons and per your
request for a challenge - see which of us
is the greater.”
The Prince of Fires moved his hands and cast
forth a merciless conflagration of stellar
flame.
682 was bathed in the fury of a thousand suns
and felt an unthinkable rush of pain, unlike
even the sword of the guardian from back home.
The fires continued to lick its form as 682
went berserk and charged towards the armies
of Rajarahan.
Quick as the spark of an ignited flame, Rajarahan
intercepted 682 and delivered a punishing
kick to the lizard’s spine.
Fire swirled around the prince’s limbs,
transforming into burning weapons.
“Do not think your quarrel is with my army.”
The prince said flatly.
“They are here to watch.”
Rajarahan swung all six of his muscular limbs,
striking away at 682 with the divine weapons
held in each.
682 cried out in agony, swinging a claw back
at the prince, and leaving a cut across the
regal being's face.
The reptile then stole a page from its fallen
adversaries and transformed its tail into
an unbreakable spear, striking Rajarahan with
a swift attack.
“Magnificent!”
Rajarahan smiled.
The battle raged on for several hours, with
both entities taking severe damage and continuing
to fight even as their bodies were wounded
with the sheer force of all the attacks given
and received.
As it dragged on, Rajarahan revealed even
greater reserves of solaric power than 682
could have believed.
Likewise, 682’s strength continued to rise
as the reptile acclimated to its ungodly strong
opponent.
Several times, 682’s body was burned entirely
to atomic ash, but was able to regenerate
and continue the struggle against the Prince
of Fire and Light.
It was much later when Rajarahan fell.
The noble golden kindle had a smile on his
face, an eternal acknowledgement that the
opponent he had faced was one truly worthy
of killing him.
“Well fought, Lord of 682.
I bequeath my army to you.
Rule the Back Rooms in my stead.”
As his essence burned to cinders, the forces
of level 966 bowed their heads to 682 - a
backrooms legend to destroy all backroom’s
legends.
Now go check out “SCP-018 - Can the Super
Ball Defeat SCP-682?”
and “Was SCP-682 Really That Hard to Kill
After All?” for more!